hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
the world is full of day traders
now that stock trading is free and
got all that free money from the
government there's a lot of people
speculating what's going on stacy
well you know
money printer go
[Applause]
and of course what always follows the
problem when it was just going to the
top 0.1 percent
um you know is the moral hazard right
moral hazard is an issue and we're going
to show you
how that plays out how that has trickled
down to the rest of the economy
as we predicted here on kaiser report
when people were piling in on their
robin hood app
into hertz a bankrupt company now we see
amateur jcpenney traders beg
judge to save them from wipeout
this is the story of american financial
markets
since especially 2008 they are only
acting
like the leaders of our financial system
like jp morgan like jamie dimon and
amateur investors who loaded up on
jcpenney shares as the retailer went
bankrupt
are now pleading with the judge to spare
them from a complete wipeout quote
i hope and pray for you to consider the
shareholders wrote 50 year old
individual investor john hart
in a letter dated may 25th one of the
dozens sent to corpus christi texas
based court overseeing the case in
recent months
so these uh day traders are trying to
get the court to make them whole
yes and um well yeah that makes sense
because they see that
the big banks they are getting bailed
out you know they don't seem to make any
mistakes remember last year we were
talking about
jp morgan they had something like 90
straight days of profitable day trading
anyone who's been day trading now knows
that it's almost impossible to get 90
straight days profitable day trading
it's because jpmorgan is able to use
hedging they can hedge their bets to
make the risk go to zero
so anytime you can make the risk go to
zero and still have a trade that could
potentially be
rewarding that's a great trade if you're
a professional
bank like jp morgan or goldman sachs had
a big quarter with
bonds jp morgan had a big quarter with
bonds that's because they're able to put
trades on with zero
risk their hedging strategies offer
complete coverage okay so that there's
zero risk
and at the end of the day they get the
bailouts of course
but you the retail person would not get
the bailout the
the money that comes from the losers on
the retail
trading that's where capital comes from
in america that's where the money comes
from
it comes from the losers remember
because in the casino
the money that fuels the casino are the
losers
right if everyone won at the casino the
casino would go out of business
right they wouldn't have any money to
pay out anybody so you need losers and
you need winners and
if you have the house like the banks who
have zero
risk similar to a casino then you
by definition must be the loser and the
government or the courts are not going
to help you
well there are no losers on the kaiser
report we have money for
everybody in our audience and you know
according to this piece
as we have warned here on kai's report
to the retail traders
on robin hood i don't know who the
regulators should be in this situation
but they have been piling in to bankrupt
companies as this article in bloomberg
points out heart is one of the growing
number of retail traders many driven by
lockdown boredom and free online trading
who have piled into the stock market
speculation by amateurs is nothing new
but for the first time
experts can recall investors are buying
shares of even bankrupt companies hertz
global for example oil driller whiting
jcpenney have all seen their stock price
surge in recent sessions despite being
in chapter 11 and then they go on to
speak to a chapter 11 bankruptcy lawyer
as we've told you here on kai's report
like you get wiped out that's what
happens
in a bankruptcy situation
but mom and pop investors who insist on
betting on struggling companies
would be well advised to stay away from
those in or near bankruptcy said fred
ringel a partner and co-chair of the
bankruptcy department at law firm
robinson broad line wind green
genovese and gluck people who buy equity
hoping that they're not going to get
wiped out in a bankruptcy
just don't understand the process or
they don't watch kaiser report well you
know this is an extension of the opiate
crisis you know the
the big opium manufacturers in america
uh oxycontin the heroin producers
you know they got millions and millions
of people hooked on heroin
and those people now are hooked on
gambling uh so
uh and don't forget pornhub so you have
a country that is
essentially degenerate right that's got
gambling
um heroin addiction and porn addiction
right so that's the
vast majority of economic activity which
is concluded in gdp by the way
so if vice could maybe triple
then the debt to gdp in america would
look better
everybody has a different opinion about
what is vice and what is not but
nobody can differ on what the free money
has done and the moral hazard of bailing
out
so this is only a natural evolution a
natural
response to what they've been noticing
since 2008
when goldman sachs packaged all those uh
fraudulent mortgages
into a fraudulent derivatives product
they got bailed out
aig got bailed out warren buffett got
bailed out all these people got bailed
out so of course
the mindset is going to happen whereby
people in the
economy think they also will get bailed
out and
that they also deserve this free money
here is a headline
out of the crypto space um
kind of because it's a guy who applied
for a fraudulent loan now most of those
loans from the ppp
the free money 500 and something billion
thrown
around the economy i'm out of dollars in
my printer but the fed's
printer and the treasury's printer never
dies texas man's alleged use of ppp
funds for crypto instead of barbecue has
feds asking where's the beef a 29 year
old texas man
is in a one trouble after being charged
monday with siphoning nearly one million
dollars in payment protection program
loans meant for a barbecue company into
a crypto
currency trading account so this guy
joshua
thomas aguirres he applied for a million
dollar loan for texas barbecue
and it turns out there was no company
called this he registered it just to
apply for this loan he had no
uh previous taxes ever paid no employees
and he instead bought bitcoin or
he they don't mention which coins he
bought but he
he speculated in cryptocurrency yeah
it's pretty crazy it's like an
entrapment scheme
right you know like they just put out
this really vaguely
worded document like so you're on your
your own accord here we thank you
if you need money you know figure it out
we'll send you some
so then the government sent out a bunch
of money and then they came back and
said wait a minute
we're actually uh going to put you in
prison
all right so um casino gulag so remember
i just described the casino of america
this is the gulag this is the gulag park
the government arbitrarily arrest people
put them into
government but they can still trade day
trade that's the great thing about the
american prison system they're going to
introduce
day trading so that they can make money
for the gdp
while in prison casino gulag you heard
it here first
well overseeing the casino gulag are of
course the central banks
working hand in hand with some of the
treasuries around the world
no don't tell me to prison don't send me
the prison
don't do it no i'm a good i'm a good
chicken
don't that's unfair you know i mean
plucky is just trying to do his job
you know he's past egg laying age but he
still does a good job as an economist
and there's no reason to send plucky to
the casino gulag
absolutely no reason so we were just
talking about this guy with the barbecue
and the fake barbecue applying for a
fake loan for a million dollars he's now
facing
charges of money laundering a wire fraud
all these sort of things who knows how
many decades he'll face behind prison
but what i was saying like with the
essential banks and the moral hazard
they've created within the economy
uh and we've quoted frederick bastiat
many times about
when plunder becomes a way of uh life
for uh you know people in an economy
then you create a moral system that
justifies it so here
is the largest bank in the world and
certainly in america and that is
jp morgan has been a big recipient of
a cut of these um 500 and something
billion in ppp loans
the fact that banks are siphoning money
off of the relief program
is thanks to the fact that the united
states had no
existing public infrastructure ready to
quickly get money out to struggling
businesses
when the pandemic hit banks stand to
make 18
billion dollars from cares act and fees
that's money taken directly out of the
640 billion dollar pot of funding
congress allocated
to the program so of course you know
they're taking 18 billion dollars
remember they made a huge fortune as
well during the 2008 financial crisis
and because we bailed them out and here
they're getting a cut of this
bailout jp morgan just reported the
highest
ever quarterly profits in their history
so
you know this is why you find
guys in texas creating fake barbecues
in order to get a million dollar loan
they feel like well jamie dimon can do
it
why can't i yeah back in the depression
remember
fdr he printed a lot of money and they
went and built stuff like roads and
bridges
and museums and radio city music hall
and the exxon building dams dams
right and then during this depression uh
the government prints a lot of money and
they gave it to jamie dimon
and then he buys expensive toys with it
so
that's the that's the government policy
to get us out of the depression it's
like
okay uh there's an opiate crisis give
jamie more money
and he'll keep it oh there's a economic
crisis give jamie more money oh the odds
companies are going bankrupt give jamie
more money
so jamie just gets all the money and he
just puts it in the bank and he
walks around and says well you need give
me more money that's the only solution
that's the or uh over there at blackrock
where they buy
the government gives them money to buy
their own
repackaging of the stocks that they
themselves
own for themselves wow
what a great idea uh so then people in
america look at that they say wait a
minute
this is the biggest corrupt scheme i've
ever seen ever this is more corrupt than
nero this is more corrupt than caligula
this is more corrupt than you know the
most corrupt
um rapacious bloodthirsty
potentate that's ever existed in
mankind's history
is the wall street and washington axis
of blood and cash and
um so the average person in america is
saying well can i at least get 10 bucks
for a cup of coffee
and they're like off to the gulag with
you
plucky tell this is plucky he'll say
stay out of the casino coulee don't say
anything online
don't ever make any money and keep the
irs
away right so heed plucky's word stay
out of the casino gulag
and don't do anything the tweet on jp
morgan wow jp morgan the biggest u.s
bank just reported its highest quarterly
revenue
ever according to ceo jamie dimon's
comment in the press release so
of course this is part of that plunder
of this ppp that somebody's going to
have to pay for
there are more of these um unaccountable
uh spewing of money coming up
and it is of course becomes tawdry
everywhere you go
is corrupt and we see that in all
nations are susceptible to it it happens
all the time we saw that in egypt when
we went there after the revolution
and the the pool guy at our hotel said
in amazement that his father had just
got his license driver's license
uh renewed and he didn't have to pay a
bribe like that was the first time that
happened and he was so shocked his whole
life he knew
having to pay bribes yeah so here you
know it's like trump makes mubarak look
like mother teresa
certainly jamie dimon well we got to
take a break and when we come back
much more coming your way so don't even
think about going away
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to turn to bob
mccalrath he is
a theoretical physicist reverse
engineering the universe
and remaking money bob welcome hello
thank you
great to have you on i've been following
your work for a number of years see you
at conferences every now and then and
this is uh great to have you on now the
bitcoin
hash rate is currently at 125 exahash
what does this number tell us both in a
technical level and then on a more
fundamental profound level bob well at a
fundamental level um
a hash is you know computation of one of
the instances of
a computation which could be a bitcoin
block right so an axa hash
is um i have to look up the
si prefix for exa but it's a 10 18. it's
an awful lot of hashes per second
um so what this means is that the we
recently had a hash rate adjustment um
so every two weeks bitcoin adjusts its
uh its hash rate target
um and it went up by quite a bit in the
last um
the last uh half or less difficulty
readjustment
what this means is that miners who are
probably some of the most
uh economically invested participants in
the ecosystem
are betting strongly on on bitcoin um
this means a couple of things it means
so first of all there's a new generation
of equipment
which is up to 100 hashes per second per
mining device at about 3 000 watts
second of all it means that those
producers of bitcoin blocks
have found cheaper sources of power you
know there's been a gold rush of sorts
looking for
cheaper and cheaper sources of power you
know the days of people mining in their
dorm rooms or buying a couple of uh
s9s and putting them in their basement
are over
you know you just cannot mine profitably
with retail electricity
um so that that is the second cause of
the hash rate going up
um and the third coin uh a third cause
is basically just
confidence in the market right um these
folks who are mining have deployed
intense amounts of capital you know to
the tune of many billions of dollars per
year
that they deploy to create bitcoin
blocks and you know the mining ecosystem
is essentially making a long-term bet
and they are betting that this ecosystem
is
is thriving and all the consequences
that would come from that
you know it's interesting because you
often hear this idea from people that
bitcoin
is quote not backed by anything and yet
it's it it's backed by these miners you
know that are converting energy
to unconfiscatable indestructible
units that we now know can be used
as a store of value and and used as
money and you mentioned how
the energy costs are really so important
to this whole thing as they are in all
mining you know whether it's gold mining
or any type of mining energy costs are a
big component to that
it appears now bob as though the center
of gravity
for bitcoin mining is actually now
moving maybe away from
china toward the u.s because the u.s has
now
got the cheapest energy is that correct
can you fill us in on that
it's difficult to know there are not any
large scale metrics
miners are intensely secretive um you
know if you
in you know the 1840s 1849 if you found
a gold vein right in san francisco or
california
you wouldn't go tell all your friends
right right you keep that to yourself so
the miners are intensely secret they
don't really publish you know where
they're getting electricity or how
but i personally have seen quite a lot
of movement toward the united states
um you know there's a great article by
nick carter talking about the mining
ecosystem and um basically the mining
ecosystem buys up the cheapest
electricity that's around
there are a lot of times and places that
electricity cannot be sold at any price
right sometimes there's overproduction
and that overproduction
you know where geographically the
overproduction was historically has been
china
and the reason for that is that china
built a lot of hydroelectric dams in the
western part of china in the mountains
um but that's not where the people live
that's not where the energy is consumed
and they did not build corresponding
transmission networks uh
so you know it wasn't possible to get
the electricity by and large from these
these hydroelectric dams to uh beijing
so there has been
historically a seasonal cycle to bitcoin
mining around the price of electricity
because
during the rainy season in china those
dams are full
right and so you you can't just you know
fill it up forever eventually the dam is
full and you have to open the sluice
gates and like let the water go
so you can either generate electricity
with that water or you just let open the
skates and let the water go
if you just let the water go this is an
energy resource that is not being tapped
at all
and is effectively free right so that's
what's been happening
in china for years is that you know
people in various municipalities in
china have
gotten deals with the local uh
administration and been able to get
access to this electricity
um china obviously has been quite
hostile
uh to bitcoin over the years um and
people are
seeking out you know more politically
stable
areas to to do this and as uh you know
big finances getting more interested in
in bitcoin um obviously the us canada um
you know western nations europe
is a big target for this and what's
happening is that
where are those similar sources of
electricity in the united states uh
a lot of that so those sources of
electricity come from aluminum mining
actually so iceland in particular had a
lot of geothermal electricity and they
considered aluminum to be their energy
export
right they had more energy you know to
do with um and so how do you export that
energy it's not profit it's not possible
to run wires from iceland to mainland
europe and sell that electricity
so they use it to create aluminum
aluminum the cost of creating aluminum
is about 50
electricity in refining the bauxite ore
um
bitcoin similarly is an energy export if
you're in a place where there's too much
energy you can sell it so
where in the united states is there too
much energy we have a tremendous oil and
gas industry here
uh you know the natural gas industry has
gone gangbusters and the price of
natural gas has gone through the floor
in recent years
um a lot of uh oil wells produce natural
gas as a side effect
um and in the us and canada there is a
lot of natural gas that um for one
reason or another
cannot be tapped uh because it's not
profitable to compress it and and store
it and transport it
or that it's intermittent or something
like that that's a fascinating way to
phrase it that it's an energy export
and i think in within those uh that kind
of um
you know view of things it's a lot
becomes clearer now you are a
theoretical physicist so this should be
right in your wheelhouse here i got to
ask you about quantum computers because
this comes up a lot people say oh you
know quantum computers are going to
challenge bitcoin
security et cetera what what where are
we on that bob
difficult question uh you know so we've
built quantum computers uh
in various ways um i'm personally of the
opinion that i don't think we're ever
going to see a quantum computer that uh
can challenge bitcoin or break bitcoin
keys
um that said there's still a lot of
interesting uses for quantum computers
even if we can't break cryptography with
it
um the reason is basically that uh
you have to create a quantum state with
an extreme precision
um and there is something out there
called the uncertainty principle
heisenberg's uncertainty principle
if you create precision in one variable
you lose it in another
um and so basically in order to create a
a state that has the precision required
to do a quantum computation to break rsa
or elliptic curves
requires a precision that is rather
extreme
the number of decimal places you've got
to get right is more than the number of
atoms in the universe
so this is just not practical i don't
think we're ever going to see that
there's another way of looking at it and
that is in terms of energy costs to
create that state
you know this in the quantum computing
industry this comes down to what they
call a quantum error correction
the idea being that i can create an
imprecise state i do some computation i
i detect and correct
the error and this requires error
correction to
be very very good and even with error
correction i
personally don't believe this is uh this
is ever going to be practical
um don't quote me on that of course i
realize i'm on your
show but uh you know the research will
continue
um and the quantum computers we've seen
so far are
very very far from anything practical
that would be uh you know applicable to
bitcoin
okay well i mean that's that's a great
insight that
that we haven't had that level of
insight yet and thank you for that so
on this general topic though of a 51
attack right so this is the idea that
somebody's going to dominate
the hash power all those um you know
quintillion of hashes per second or
calculations per second will fall into
the hands of one player
maybe a state actor or a group of state
actors
it seems that the game theory part of
the
bitcoin protocol precludes that from
happening and in fact and i'm curious
what you think about this
the protocol almost invites these types
of attacks because the more attacks it
gets from people who think they can take
it over
then the security goes up the hash rate
actually goes up as you point out the
difficulty adjustment every two weeks
would go
up and therefore the security would go
up and therefore the price would go up
so it's almost like a red queen
syndrome where the more you attack it
the harder it is to attack bob what do
you think
not technically correct so if if you
performed a 51
attack and you had 51 of the hash rate
um basically what you're doing is the
other 49
will still produce blocks and you're
going to orphan all of them so your
difficulty adjustment would actually be
down
after that phase of an attack you'd drop
by roughly a factor of two because
only 50 51 of the network is actually
contributing uh useful blocks the other
of the blocks got orphaned um but
you know as uh mining is getting more
distributed um
you know more and more people are
getting involved in mining uh you know
institutional players are getting
involved in mining the u.s is getting
involved in mining
um there are more entities right
um the more entities there are uh
involved in mining the more difficult it
is to gather
uh 51 percent um and you know we're
entering an era with mining where
up to now the the the mo has been to get
uh continuous power
um you know you want that hydroelectric
power you want it 24 hours a day for the
lifetime of the equipment
and you keep running it um as miners
seek
cheaper and cheaper power one thing
they're going to start doing is turning
off their equipment uh during times when
electricity price is too high
um you know the the you can think about
like a a geographic landscape right and
the miners are essentially filling in
the very lowest length like pouring
water on a mountain right it flows down
and
they suck up all the very cheapest power
um where that
cheapest power is intermittent um it
comes from things like renewables solar
and wind
the sun isn't always shining the wind
isn't always blowing and when the sun is
shining
those things often overproduce energy
and so the the there's a now a duty
cycle to these things this has been
happening in the pacific northwest for a
while
um the there is a demand pricing of
electricity up there where
uh the price will go um down during the
night and up during the day and so
miners in that area
many of them have been turning off their
equipment when the price is high so
anyway
you get more and more and more
distribution more and more people and
it's more and more difficult to suck up
51 and now that they're also turning off
their equipment sometime they can turn
it back on
uh you know and and take slight loss
when their livelihood is at stake right
when there's a threat of an attack like
that
at some point i do want to circle back
on that 51
attack on the difficulty adjustment
question but not today we'll do that
another time i want to move on i want to
ask you about
hardware in the hardware sector so we've
got bit main
uh was recently dominating the industry
it looks like they're on the verge of
collapse from what i understand
uh are there other manufacturers to fill
in the gap do we need more competition
is this what you'd expect in this
industry it seems like game theory just
is working in all layers of the stack
bob
yes um there have been more companies
coming in um
uh ebang recently uh announced their ipo
there the manufacturer of bitcoin
hardware
uh what's minor right was started by uh
the lead engineer bit main leaving
bitmain informing his own company they
make some very good equipment
there are a handful of other smaller
ones uh but we're still kind of
constrained by the fact that
uh you know the u.s lost its
manufacturing base a long time ago
and chips are manufactured in by and
large in china and taiwan
so even uh even if you have different
companies manufacturing they're probably
going to still have to go to
taiwan and china to manufacture this
equipment fascinating stuff
left to be on again soon to follow up
really interesting stuff bob mcgowan
thanks for being on the kaiser report
thank you and that's going to do it for
this edition of the kaiser report with
me max kaiser and stacey herbert like to
thank our guest bob mcgowan
if you want to catch us on twitter it's
kaiser report until next time
bye y'all
[Music]